so let's say you're walking down the
street and i'm going to draw you here
and you decide to do a little experiment
you take a deep breath
as you're walking and you decide to blow
out through a cardboard tube
something like that
and let's say it's like a toilet paper
roll
and so you blow out through it and here
in this toilet paper roll
the length is let's call l
and here there's a radius and i'll call
it r and we know that toilet paper roll
is let's say about two centimeters
radius that may not be exactly right but
let's just assume that
and you do this and you find that it's
so easy to do very easy to take one
breath of air and blow it out through a
cardboard tube and so you decide to do
it slightly differently so you do it
again and now you do it slightly
differently now you go ahead and
take
an equally
an equal size breath but you instead of
a tube you choose a straw
and that straw is obviously much
skinnier
and you try and you find that it's
actually really hard to blow air through
that straw
not as easy as it was before and so you
find that it's much much more difficult
and you want to figure out why and you
know the tube
was l and this straw is the exact same
length l
and the radius now is smaller so instead
of r let's call this r prime
and instead of two centimeters this one
is about let's say one centimeter it's a
pretty big straw still but let's just
assume that for the moment
so you want to figure out why in the
world is it harder with the straw and
this question posed slightly differently
was asked actually a long time ago
by a gentleman a french gentleman by the
name of dr jean louis marie
and i'm actually probably mispronouncing
that a little bit so i apologize to any
of dr bossa's relatives but this is a
frenchman and i'm going to spell out his
name for you
he actually lived in the 1800s
was born actually in the 1700s but lived
in the 1800s and this is a you
and in the 1840s he put together a set
of equations that helps us answer that
question that i just asked which is
about
why was it more difficult in one
situation
to the next so he said if you have a
tube
and you're trying to get a fluid through
that tube so in this case not air but a
fluid
but you'll see that a lot of the
math is very similar
he said if you know the length of the
tube let's call it l just as we did
before and if you know the viscosity and
viscosity he calls eta
eta
now this is viscosity of the fluid
if you know these things and lastly if
you know the radius
if you know the radius then you can
actually calculate the resistance and he
said the resistance
resistance
and
i'll just call that r from now on big r
not to confuse or confuse you with
little r which is radius
equals eight times the length times the
viscosity divided by the number pi
times the radius to the fourth power now
that might look confusing but
look at this we actually have a lot of
these values we know the length of a
tube we can probably figure out the
viscosity
and all we need to do is measure the
radius and we have the resistance so
it's pretty powerful formula
and we can actually use this to
understand what happened earlier so in
this earlier example
i'm going to go back to this now let's
take that resistance formula so big r
equals and we said 8 times
l times
the resistance
over
pi
times
r to the fourth
and
i'm just going to go ahead and
replace this with
resistance is proportional therefore to
one over r to the fourth and you can see
why that's the case because
all of this other stuff
all this stuff
can be figured out in this example and
you can see that there's a relationship
between these two things let me just
draw them
r
and little r and the relationship is
stated here right so you have as the
radius gets very very very big
the resistance is going to get very very
small and in fact it's going to happen
very quickly because you're raising the
radius to the fourth power now let me
take this one step further let's look at
the other side now so over here we have
a situation where we said
we have again rate resistance equals
eight times
the length
times viscosity divided by pi
so far it should look the same obviously
right and here's the big change so
instead of r i'm going to say r prime
to the fourth power now what's the
relationship between the two things so
we said that if r is two centimeters r
prime is one centimeter that means that
r prime
equals
r divided by two
and of course i made up these numbers so
that relationship is just for this
example
and so if r prime equals r over 2 i'm
going to replace that in my equation so
just as before i'm just going to say r
is now proportional to 1 over r prime to
the fourth power
which means
that r is proportional to
i'll just keep writing it out
one
over
r over two to the fourth power
which means r is proportional to
one over r
to the fourth over 16. because 2 to the
4th power is 16 right and it's in the
denominator here
and so if we flip it up to the top we
see something really really cool which
is that it's
16
over r to the fourth so in other words
compare the first example where you had
r proportional to one
over r to the fourth and now you have r
is proportional to 16 over r to the
fourth that means that it's harder
because the resistance
is
let me just write that out again
16 times greater
that's remarkable you just dropped the
radius a little bit you know you went
from two centimeters to one centimeter
and the and the resistance went up 16
times and that's why it was so hard so
now let's apply this to blood vessels
so if you now
understand the idea that you have
blood vessels and they're basically like
tubes and you can probably see where
this analogy is going
there are parts of the blood vessels
that are called arterioles so that's a
part of the circulatory system
arterioles
and these arterials have a very
interesting property and that is that if
you look at them closely they're covered
with smooth muscle so all these bands of
smooth muscle
kind of wrap around
this arterial and what it does is that
when the smooth muscle is relaxed let's
say it's very relaxed
relaxed
then you get something like this
and if it's uh let's say squeezing down
or tightening
let's say constricting
then you get something like this and you
can probably guess what i'm about to
draw something like that
and i haven't drawn the smooth muscle
here but you can still guess
it's basically like this these are just
wide open relaxed you know completely
at ease
and these are tight very very tight and
that's why they're bringing the diameter
and therefore the radius
of the
vessel
down so this radius
compared to this radius it's just like
our cardboard tube versus our straw and
so when it's relaxed we call this vaso
vaso meaning vessel
dilation
and when it's constricted we call it
same thing vaso for vessel constriction
and the reason that
we want to make this distinction is that
we know based on this example now that
when you have vasodilation what that
means
for the
blood
is that you're going to have
very low
resistance
so blood can flow through
with very low resistance and when you
have vasoconstriction now you can see
why
that means you're going to have high
resistance
and so we owe a lot of this
understanding and thinking to dr wassot
from the 1840s